NOW AND IT STARTED WITH
MATTHEWS' PUT-BACK ON GIANNIS'
MISSED FREE THROW.
>> Reggie: YOU DON'T NECESSARILY
NEED A THREE RIGHT HERE.
IF YOU CAN GET A QUICK TWO AND
SET YOUR DEFENSE.
YOU DO HAVE THE ONE TIME-OUT IF
YOU GET A STOP AT THE OTHER END
TO ADVANCE THE BROOKLYN.
>> Kevin: HOLIDAY HAS IT AND
DURANT COMES OUT ON HIM.
HOLIDAY WILL DRIVE AND LOOK FOR
GIANNIS AND OUT TO CONNAUGHTON.
ANTETOKOUNMPO, STEP-BACK THREE
FOR THE TIE.
GOT IT!
GIANNIS TIES THE GAME AND
BECOMES THE BUCKS' ALL-TIME
LEADING SCORER ON ONE STROKE.
>> Reggie: ONLY FITTING.
ONLY FITTING.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO PASS THE
GREAT KAREEM ABDUL JABAR, YOU
MIGHT AS WILL DO IT IN
SPECTACULAR FASHION.
10-BACK THREE FROM GIANNIS.
THE SAME SHOT HE GOT ON THE
PREVIOUS POSSESSION.
BUT HE WAS MORE IN RHYTHM WITH
THE BIG FELLA, ANDRE DRUMMOND,
TRYING TO GUARD HIM ON THE
PERIMETER.
TAKES A LOOK AT THE OPPOSITE
CLOCK AND HOW MUCH TIME YOU HAVE
LEFT.
A CROSSOVER STEP-BACK.
CASH MONEY RULES.
>> Kevin: ANTETOKOUNMPO HAD 40
IN PHILLY ON TUESDAY.
HE HAS 42 TONIGHT.
BACK-TO-BACK 30-POINT